Cô bún thì sao nó cô phân lại của bún thì này rồi
Cô bún nó cô bún nó cô sách xuất
và cô này nó cô một chủng tục khó nhìn thấy
Cái em phải nắng được
Thuy nhất là bà nó chứ đi
Tưởng hai nó bó phân tự này
Thử bà nó không bị nạc ở đây nữa
Nhà
Thì các bạn thấy nó chúng ta thấy nó chẳng đến phân bù nữa
Tờ 1 bà toàn game kết thêm rất nhiều phương pháp
Mà các pháp để thiệu như thế này sẽ các bạn này trong việc pháp
Sữa thế rồi
Nhưng mà nó là kết được nhiều phân phán nhau
Nhan game nhiều khi trong thị game của hơi bị cô đối
Chúng không có chình như vậy này
Đối với các năm này thì nó bà toàn cũng
Vừa vừa vừa vừa vừa vừa vừa tốt
Nó hồi thiết khu trọng xanh trù về lo kìm sẽ được hảm
Mà kìm biết được tận nầm đâu